مشاهدينا على نطاق واسع سارع دول عربيه
وحكومات اجنبيه باجلاء رعاياها من السودان
الامر الذي اعده البعض مؤشرا على طول امد
الحرب عمليه الاجلاء المتسارعه تتم عبر
البحر والجو والبرق كذلك السعوديه كانت
اول الدول التي نظمت عمليه الاجلاء بحرا
من ميناء بورتسودان عند هذه النقطه من
الخريطه على البحر الاحمر الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه في مدينه جده حيث هذه النقطه
بمشاركه سفن جلاله الملك ينبع وجلاله
الملك الجبيل وسفينه امانه كذلك تمكنت من
نقل الاف من السعوديين والعرب والاجانب من
دبلوماسيين كذلك جوا تعددت نقاط الاجلاء
طائرات حربيه من قاعده امريكيه في جيبوتي
انطلقت الى السودان لاجلاء جميع الموظفين
الامريكيين وعائلتهم كذلك مطار بورسودان
الدولي كان كذلك نقطه اخرى لعمليه الاجلاء
هنا المطار دول اخرى انشات جسرا جويا
عسكريا حيث نقلت بريطانيا رعاياها مثلا
عبر طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني الى مطار لارناكا في قبرص وعن
طريق البر خرج رعايه تركيا من الخرطوم برا
الى العاصمه هنا من الخرطوم خرجوا الى
العاصمه الاثيوبيه حيث اجلت انقره رعاياها
من هناك في حين شهد معبر قسطل وارقين في
مصر وصوله عشرات الالاف هنا المعبران هنا
لدينا قسطل وارقين وشهد عبور عشرات الالاف
من الاشخاص وسط انتشار للقوات الامنيه
المصريه لتامين عمليه الاجلاء والنزوح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات